Oh Dave you're on the air yes sir
I can't thank you enough dr. for all
your support sir okay well god bless how
can we help you today I got a lady that
I called you about some time ago she's 5
foot 265 pounds and 51 years old
she's got no thyroid and I put her on
the healthy body pack the oceans both
the ultimate enzymes the flora effects
but she's got good intones it also gave
her the good job although she tells me
that the oceans gold made her feel
uncomfortable gave her a headache so she
stopped taking it that's what she thinks
okay so when they when you stop taking
the ocean gold to the headaches go away
yes it did okay little while but then
again
now she's got chest pain she she can't
beat properly and she's got headaches
again it might not be that that's right
okay she's still that taking the others
old wasn't the oceans gold okay well one
of the time one of the things that can
cause headaches is a low blood sugar
thing what could be happening here char
okay char as this Dame has got a ladies
he's five foot two 165 so she's maybe 50
pounds or more overweight she's got her
thyroid has been removed I'm sure she's
untie roids medication for that and
she's got these headaches that are kind
of constant since she's started taking
the products and let's say she's getting
reactive hyperglycemia what's that
caused it why she got reactive and have
a glycine when she starts taking the
products which would then cause a
headache
I don't know well of course you do
okay when you have low blood sugar you
can oftentimes have a headache from low
blood sugar he can get drowsy get a
headache also when you have a thyroid
problem maybe they thought she had a
hyperactivity the thyroid and instead of
just you know giving her nutritional
programs they just took her thyroid out
and put on medication and so what would
you give her for blood sugar problems
well I've give her the healthy blood
sugar pack well there you go you get an
A+ on that one
give her the healthy blood sugar packet
I'd go ahead and just to the program
you've got Ron Dave just keep that same
program but add to it the sweeties I get
two bottles of sweetie so she can take
three breakfasts three dinner time out
also we have a new one that's called
Lucas glue connects is that correct char
coca genex Oh Lucas genex there you go
gluco genex and so I would add that in
addition to the three sweeties twice a
day I get a bottle of the glue kinetics
so you can take two or three of those at
lunch okay that way she'll be taking a
blood sugar supplement at breakfast
lunch and dinner time just for healthy
blood sugar levels but make sure that
she's not eating a lot of carbohydrates
and sweets now what would you do for the
weight loss piece to lose 50 pounds I
would give the rug but also is it
possible that she could have food
allergies and that could be causing
headaches anything is possible but let's
do what we can do yeah the rebbe for the
weight loss
yeah for the weight loss okay put her
drop her full under her tongue 30
minutes for each meal and she'll lose
1/2 a pound of two pounds of Daisy
realistically in 2 to 3 or 4 months she
can certainly lose a half a pound to 2
pounds a day and get herself down to 115
pounds which would be more correct from
5 foot 2 and we may want to put that
OSHA's gold back in there since taking
it away didn't stop the headaches but
it's not unusual and somebody is really
severely deficient and in these secret
sauces that are necessary to support a
healthy blood sugar levels and to
support healthy sugar and carbohydrate
metabolism when they're deficient in
those nutrients and they eat a lot of
carbohydrates like bread and pasta and
pizza crusts and biscuits and crackers
cereals for breakfast and all that kind
of stuff now when do they have a gluten
problem they also have a carbohydrate
sugar problem and then you throw in
something that's going to drop their
blood sugar okay guess what okay you can
get headaches so let's try this out and
and put the glucose etics is that
correct correct
good good genex yeah yeah gluco genex
okay
luca geniux take turn three of those
tablets at lunchtime and take the
sweeties three of those twice's so it'll
be two bottles of the sweeties and one
bottle
Lucca genex and then give us call in two
weeks in four weeks in six weeks she can
start to diet immediately now it's gonna
take her and if she wants to she can
lose some weight faster get a hold of
the keto caramel shake for one or two
meals a day or the keto caramel meal bar
210 one calories one or two meals a day
and then steamed vegetables and poultry
you seen vegetables and fish steamed
vegetables and red meat steamed
vegetables and eggs eggs eggs eggs but
keep her away from the carbohydrates and
let us see if those headaches don't stop